in the woods of Westeros lives a woman
small and aged but skin is pale as milk
and eyes red like fire she dreams of the
future and sees into the souls of those
she encounters many of her prophecies
have proven to be true though some have
not yet come to fruition this woman
known as the ghost of high heart has
lived through many historic events in
Westeros including the fire at the
Targaryen Castle summer hall I got Don
grief at summer hall I'll have none of
yours the ghost of high heart here is
seemingly referring to Ginny of old
stone who died in the summer hall fire
Ginny was the wife of Prince Duncan the
small who defied his father the king
just to be with her according to rumor
Ginny had befriended a dwarf woods witch
but how can we be sure that the ghost of
high heart is the same witch in a Storm
of Swords the Brotherhood without
banners encounters the ghost on the hill
of high heart the place where she takes
her name in exchange for her prophecies
she asked only for a song specifically
Jenny song so we know that she was
greatly saddened by the events at summer
hall we know that Ginny befriended a
wood switch and we know that the ghost
asked for a song about a girl named
Ginny it seems very likely that the
woods Witch and the ghost of high heart
are the same person but there is more to
this according to the stories the woods
which Ginny befriended gave a prophecy
as well she prophesized that the prince
that was promised would be born from the
line of Prince Aerys Targaryen and
Princess Ariel a Targaryen
when jaehaerys ii caught wind of his
prophecy he declared that the two
children be married this would mean that
the ghost of high heart had a greater
influence on Westeros than it would seem
on the surface without her prophecy
Aerys may have not married ray Ella and
Rhaegar the series Dany even perhaps
John would not have been born
according to the ghosts of high heart
her visions come to her in dreams and
she believes they are sent by the old
gods the old gods stir and will not let
me sleep we know that a top high heart
lies a circle of chopped down where with
trees we do not know what this place was
once used for but it was likely a place
of great power for the children of the
forest if the ghost of high heart is
hearing whispers from the old gods this
could mean only one thing the children
of the forest are involved in some way
take a closer look at Jenny of Old Stone
and the story seems to clear even more
Prince Duncan discovered her whilst
traveling through the Riverlands
she lived rather crudely half-wild
amongst ancient ruins and claimed
herself to be descended from ancient
kings of the first men the small folk in
the villages near Jenny's ruins mocked
her however insisting that she was mad
and perhaps even a witch Jenny and the
ghost have appeared to be very close the
ghost even accompanied Jenny to court
according to the world of Ice and Fire
and even more strangely Jenny herself
claimed that the woman was a child of
the forest though different and
appearance the ghosts of high heart has
a few physical indicators that would tie
her to the children bloodraven told bran
that amongst the children of the forest
most had green or yellow eyes but one in
every thousand had red eyes and was a
green seer the ghost has red eyes the
children are also said to be as small as
children
the ghost is described as a dwarf woman
is it possible that she gets close
ancestry with the children but how could
this be possible when the children had
not been seen in Westeros for thousands
of years they may have not been seen but
that does not mean at the
not there according to lief one of the
children of the forest she had traveled
the lands of Westeros hidden in the
shadows for at least two centuries leaf
was born in the time of the Dragon
meaning during the reign of the
Targaryen Kings and left Westeros with a
weary heart leaf is also the only one of
the children of the forest in blood
Ravens cave that speaks the common
tongue little is known about the anatomy
of the children of the forest but is it
possible that the ghosts of high heart
is somehow descended from leaf and may
perhaps even be her daughter this would
explain why she left Westeros with a
weary heart knowing that she left her
child behind but let's not stop there
there was a reason that Ginny and the
ghost of high heart were so close there
is a reason that even after nearly half
a century
the ghost still grieves for Ginny and
asks only for a song of her in exchange
for her dreams there is a reason that
Ginny was viewed as strange by the small
folk and lived amongst ruins in the
forests of the Riverlands that's right
I'm suggesting that Ginny and the ghost
of high heart were more than just
friends
I am suggesting that the ghost and Jenny
are mother and daughter both likely with
the blood of the children of the forest
and the first men but this brings up
another question why would lief have a
half-human child in the first place
perhaps the reason is because a child
that was at least part human would blend
in easier amongst humans leaf also said
that she walked Westeros to listen and
learn it would make sense that after she
retreated back to the far north that the
children would want someone else in the
south to keep an eye on humanity
the ghost in fact does seem to be still
in contact with the children mentioning
that the old gods whispered to her at
night aka the weirwood trees and Jenny
votes on herself would have been queen
of all the Seven Kingdoms if not for
Duncan renouncing his crown in favor of
his younger brother at the center of all
the kingdom's politics and drama she
would have been the perfect spy for the
children of the forest it would have
been the perfect place for her to listen
and learn just as lief had done for 200
years but her life was instead claimed
by the fires at summer hall now only her
soul has remained and the withering
ghost of high heart thank you guys for
watching if you like this content make
sure you check out my patreon and like
and subscribe for more ideas of Ice and
Fire